In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadion from A-20th on which we commemorate St. Lydia.
St. Lydia was a native of the city of Thyatira and professed the Jewish faith although a Gentile.
She was a dire of purple and lived with her family at Philippi in Macedonia.
One Sabbath day St. Paul went to preach to the devout women who were gathered outside the city near the river in order to perform the ritual ablutions.
When Lydia heard him speak of the Savior and of the kingdom of God, the Lord opened her heart and she immediately asked to be baptized with all her family.
After the ceremony, she begged the Apostle and his fellow-workers, Luke and Silas to stay at her house and, when they refused, constrained them with a holy insistence.
Paul and Silas, having been beaten with rods and thrown into prison after a popular uprising provoked by their presence in the city, were delivered through divine intervention and went to Lydia's house.
Where they met the Christians of the city who had gathered there.
After exhorting them to remain firm in the faith, Paul and Silas then continued their travels towards Thessalonica.
St. Lydia finished her days faithful to the teaching and example of the Apostles.
It is probable that she had already found rest when St. Paul addressed his epistle to the Philippians in about the year 56 to 57, for he does not mention her.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.